he is Josh Duhamel good to see you sir
thank you for that plug it's the truth
man it's the truth and I want to get
deeper into the movie in a second but
every single minute I'm doing what
you're doing which is checking to see if
Kirk Cousins is actually signed with the
Minnesota Vikings yeah and that's the
real news here now I don't know if you
heard the way I described you in the
first set is it an accurate that was
pretty accurate I would say listen the
guys he can't there's no doubt he's a
talented quarterback oh it's a setup no
he can throw the ball all over the field
right but I want to see him win a game
in the clutch I haven't seen that yet
I'm not saying he can't do it I just
want to see him do it and that's been
our biggest hurdle at the quarterback
position over the years I thought I
actually thought that keenum was great
this year you in the clutch he was
really great I trust that you know
they're gonna they're making the right
moves over there I guess they know they
would you're saying exactly what I've
been saying what so many people in the
NFL information whose business has been
saying it's like they've got a know
their roster better than us yeah and
they do they've made some great moves
over the last few years
you know through the draft through you
know free agency I think that you know
Spielman said an amazing job I love
coach Zimmer I think this team is on
track I mean we could have just as we
could have we could have been there this
year we could have been in the net one
in that building to add I was at the
game in Philly and you man oh god you
know I was at the game the week before
in Minneapolis when when Diggs caught
thought okay got the miracle last-second
touch stuff that I did not know Josh
know so walk me through that moment I've
never been in a place more joy like with
more communal joy in my life I mean
everybody was hugging everybody you just
worried didn't matter who was your just
rival it's just like literally I saw
people crying jumping up and down nobody
could believe it cuz that just does not
happen to the Vikings you know they
they're usually the team that sort of
gets beat like that but that's why I
think that you know Zimmer's got this
thing turned around and I trust that
they're making the right choices I think
Cousins could be a really good
quarterback and I think this might be
the opportunity for him to prove it
right but being in that building will
in a second I just want to know what
that was like the only thing I could
remember that I've ever seen was and I
wasn't emotionally invested in it was
the end of the Super Bowl between the
Seahawks and the Patriots mmm
we're Seahawks are going in yeah whole
building think Seahawks are gonna win
Seahawks fans are thoroughly elated yeah
they're going back to back when they
picked him off and then and then
Patriots fans are thinking it's over and
I've never seen a switch flipped like
that before where the entire stadium
switched emotions I couldn't imagine
what it would have been in a stadium
where it was all the whole stadium was
down it was whole stadium was noisy oh
my god was the best feeling I could not
stop jumping up and down I was hugging
everybody around me you were that you
know man it was it was the best feeling
and then the next week I think because
of that high from the week before I
think we were flat the next week going
into Philly but Philly was if it was a
good football team they they they
outright beat us so but you were there
in keenum throws the first touchdown
you're thinking it's just the last week
they still write down and they just
smacked him right around and then
nothing after that couple early
turnovers that's right and that sort of
shifted the momentum and I think that
you know from there we just were never
able to catch back up Josh Duhamel
you're on the Rich Eisen show and there
is breaking news
not about Kirk Cousins but about Sam
Bradford is that what's going on right
now Sam Bradford is going according to
Arizona ugh just shefter he's going to
Arizona that's not a bad fit right stay
healthy yeah that's Sam - I mean you did
another capable quarter like he just I
don't trust him staying healthy yeah I
saw you know he just looked like you
just didn't want to get hit anymore you
know you'd go through that many that
many injuries years I think you start to
get a little bit gunshot and that's a
listen look at me I played quarterback
yeah how about the smallest school you
can imagine now and I hated getting hit
what I would contact at all but what
school is this again - State University
why not stay yep go beavers by the way
you could have given me ten cracks at
the animal that they were named after I
wouldn't have gotten that one and the
Beavers baby the Minot State Beavers
that's a University of you and so what
number were you
just a we're number 11 for anybody in
particular I guess think I was a Drew
Bledsoe fan I think that's me that might
have been the reason why but Aikman was
always the quarterback that I really
loved growing up and just as a little
segue my son too started playing t-ball
and I was gonna put him in number 11 for
his t-ball first tee ball Jersey yeah
you know cuz his grandpa wore it I wore
it okay I figured I pass it down him the
number was taken one either teen was
also taken which was the year he was
born so I was gonna give him twenty one
which is my dad's number in college but
he didn't want 21 okay okay well you can
pick what number he goes 60 number six
number one in your heart yeah what's
name Axl Axl do you know yep
out there number six in your program so
but so so let me ask you this though you
know in in pros that if somebody already
has the number you can offer something
up to swim I mean I would imagine a four
and a half year old would be easily
influenced to try and call you all right
right that's a good idea
we're actually late to sign up so I
figured I was already pushing it just
the fact that they even let us on the
team you're the late signer yeah okay so
what's Axl's game I mean is he righty
lefty do we know you I'm teaching him to
hit from both sides man well he doesn't
know any better when I'm all and I'm
putting out tape little bases on the
floor yeah and and I each base I'll put
an M&M and if he hits it past me and
gets to run a first base and it's it's
like training a dog you know what my
wife or not that's how we potty-trained
our kids with M&Ms really yes to the
point of ZAR a powerful to normal let me
tell you mewling to the point where
today my nine-year-old would call an M&M
a potty cake yeah you drop I never
thought about dropping one on third base
and say go hit a triple you know what if
he gets it past me he runs all over 30
what better motivation man Josh Duhamel
here on the Rich Eisen show I want to
take a 60-second break come back talk
about your brackets and what you think
might win it all
mmm and then talk about all your
projects don't you love salmon which
again is a tremendous movie back in 60
seconds with Josh Duhamel here on the
Rich Eisen show and there's their news
about a patriot wide receivers that what
you're saying yes unfortunate okay yes
the Patriot fan is eating poop over
there I wonder what that's all about 60
seconds not M&Ms
all right welcome back to the Rich Eisen
show Josh Duhamel hanging out here for
another segment what do you have over
there what's the news the Patriots what
yeah looks like Dan Hally of NFL
Network's saying that the Danny Amendola
is gonna sign with the Miami Dolphin
he's going reverse Welker reverse why
you never never do that what does that
mean Welker went from the Dolphins to
the Patriots oh and that worked out
pretty well it's been so good in the
playoffs the last few years
gonna miss him he has been huh little
injury prone but he's a good receiver
another hard-nosed receiver who Amendola
yeah but nobody's more hard-nosed than
Jarvis Landry I don't know why they let
him walk I don't understand it it's
certainly when they could have paid him
what what what I don't know maybe they'd
have the money to pay him peddle movie
back Tony Edelman will be back yeah I
love Edelman too have you met him yeah
he's a fun dude I think he would have a
career in acting if he so chose would
you agree he's a little character yeah I
think so the swagger right he's funny
yeah he's a handsome fella he's I've
never seen him do a monologue can you do
Shakespeare I I bet you he could I don't
have to do ever do that you've never
done Shakespeare no no not even in high
school you know it's really somewhat its
version I've done some like scene work
okay but I've never pro he'll play up
okay no so you look it once one scene of
Shakespeare and then yeah you just put
them together just one one scene at a
time just like the NFL what Shakespeare
play would you want to do to end Romeo
and Juliet Yeah right
spoiler alert if I could only be I'm
just always trying to be there 30 years
younger stop just like I was telling you
how do I have a son who's a senior in
high school I know that when did that
happen in love Simon I mean that's what
you're pretty a grandfather let's get
into that here I watched over the
weekend in advance of you being here you
played the dad in this film and Jennifer
Garner plays the mom Nick Robinson plays
Simon yeah and he is a kid in high
school who realizes he's gay and
his journey is chronicled in this film
and to me it felt like to me this was
like a John Hughes movie had he still
been alive knew and made a movie where
the central character in high school was
a kid trying to figure out how to come
out of the claws yeah it does very much
have that John Hughes feel I thought
Berlanti greg berlanti who I did a movie
called life as we know it years ago with
who's me remained a really good friend
one of my favorite people in the
business she's just about as nice as
they come and he asked me to do it and I
was you know I read I read the script
loved it especially the scene in the
driveway when I get to sort of talk to
him about it and as I play a guy who is
you know he has no clue that his son is
gay mm-hmm therefore he'll make little
jokes here and there not realizing how
insensitive it is which then you know
gives him an opportunity later to really
just apologize and say listen man I love
you no matter what but you're right I
think that it does have that sort of
coming-of-age John Hughes I love the
music of the movie that's great and then
there just the interaction of the
teenagers together and at Tony Hale is
in it today's graphic is hilarious he
plays I guess the principal or assistant
principal who tries to be all hip but
who takes away their phones the kids
phones and that's another thing about if
John Hughes was alive today there would
have been a lot about a social media
phones and that has a large role to play
in how you know your Simon's secret
comes out yeah and I do have to tell you
this the scene of you being the dad
talking it out with Simon yes that's not
easy to do you know sometimes I will cry
it like anything to do with you know
kids or whatever I'll cry commercials
whatever but this was a father you can
understand it you know you know you
truly do love your kids no matter what
and I put myself in this situation so if
this would happen if this if this news
came out with my son I want him to be
happy at the end of the day
want him to be more than more than how
the world treats him I want to know how
he's gonna treat the world I want him to
be a kind compassionate person not like
because he'll be strong enough to be
able to take whatever comes his way
and will he be able to pay it forward
and be that that person who shows
everybody the same respect they deserve
that's what this movie is about yeah and
again it's it's really it's really
awesome
it really is topped top to bottom start
to finish everybody acting in it the
writing the music and all that love
Simon in theaters Friday March 16th how
do I make the segue to to Tupac and
Biggie just make the segue I just throw
it out there and talk about what's
unsolved which is on tonight again you
play detective Greg cating in that
illness so it's it's it's it's a show
based on the two investigations that
went on in 96 and 2006 the original one
with detective Poole right after biggie
got shot not far from here the
anniversary just happened yeah I believe
just last week 9th right yeah and so he
so there's this so it kind of jumps
between two time periods and it's really
about you know Tupac biggie as human
beings and it's it's reminiscent of like
the old jet people versus OJ mm-hmm they
came out last year the year before and
that I thought I knew everything there
was to know about the OJ trial before
that show came on because I skipped
class in college to see the try but I
was addicted to it and this is the same
idea you get you sort of pull back the
curtains and get to see how these deaths
affected the people around them how it
affected the detectives trying to solve
it you know were the cops involved were
they not you know all that kind of stuff
that is really you know for me it was
fascinating because that's what I listen
to mid 90s I love Tupac and Biggie yeah
it's on USA Network every Tuesday
including tonight ten episode season
it's coming to a conclusion real soon so
check it out and then the Buddy games
which you corrected yeah wrote and
starred in hell of a cast right here
with Olivia Mont Dax Shepard fellow
Viking nut nicks Ward's yep Kevin Dillon
and more yeah James Roday is fantastic
and Dan back it all is great in it
it's just you know it's a story it's
based on this thing that my friends and
I do every year called the Buddy games
we get to it's an excuse to
together and drink and compete it's
pretty much what it is it's like it's
like a yearly reunion with with all the
old friends and we compete we do like
little competitions well ours is
everything from from paintball to
go-cart racing to ping pong to golf
mm-hmm the movie yes is absurd it is
ridiculous and it's hilarious
the games are obviously a little bit
heightened because it's a it's a movie
for example one of this is one of the
games is are they safe for work it seems
like you're going that your head is -
what
what's a kosher for the show but it's
really you know one of it one of them is
one of them is you know these guys have
these stakes strapped to their heads and
they're in this dome they don't know
where they are because I don't I'm
there's a leader of the group I don't
tell them they're our heads are poking
out of these holes mm-hmm and all you
can see is their heads with these stakes
strapped to the heads and they're like
what the hell we doing here I know hold
on and then a little bit later I say
enter the dragon a komodo dragon comes
in and they have to in whoever can keep
their head above board the longest wins
that particular competition and they're
playing for a hundred fifty thousand
bucks so you know to have real reason to
stay stay above board
tell me Swardson is in that scene
Swardson is that source and almost wins
it we we try to get Swardson
to be the Rich Eisen show correspondent
for the actual Super Bowl Thursday press
conferences final press conferences for
both the Eagles and the page and why did
he do it because I think he just could
not after that loss yeah you know you
took that pretty hard he could not bring
himself he took that long we had him
credential and everything right we did
did you how much leave it as you have to
go through to get Norton NIC approved to
do that well you know I think we snuck
him underneath the radar we did yeah we
should come underneath the radar we I
think we here's the interesting we
credentialed him his Adam Schefter and
we just put his photograph he's walking
hard are oh I know it so we were going
back and forth I realize you know you're
representing the show if you do this
a walking heart our Ella bet I don't
want to dial back mix water no you know
who do you have in your final for Josh
to melt you got you just dip it on my
way here I have literally on the drive
out here I have can I look at that yeah
I can tell you here's your bracket
here's a bracket you want him to join
our bracket I'd love to
yes okay I have can you can you cheat on
me I don't know that usually he's in
dance pool but maybe we can do both well
my self I have Arizona okay out of the
West I have North Carolina mm-hmm out of
the east
I have Villanova I think you to
Villanova getting beat I think by Purdue
do i Purdue in the font in the front for
there and I have Duke and I have Duke
playing Arizona in the championship and
I have Arizona with it Wow that's
old-school Duke versus Arizona we've
seen that before we have okay um now do
you do you have to choose South Dakota
State did the Dakotas stick together
yeah we do kind of I mean we share the
same last name so you have to did you
take them or did I have them win in the
first round on Ohio State so yeah you
know I would love yourself actually
that's that's to Ohio State this year
pretty damn good are they yeah they're
really really good they know they're
like ten but not medicine so you have
North Carolina beating my school
Michigan or Michigan going pretty far
okay all right state they did twice and
yet they're hanging out in Kansas for
the first couple rounds fantastic it's
great to see you sir as always Congrats
on everything going on with you I think
we met on a flight to Vegas you just did
the win a date with oh my god with tad
Hamilton right block yeah we did and you
were two outs what you just want to talk
Vikings football though yeah man I mean
you're pure you are you're not just
hopping on any bandwagon spikes you sure
do
well congrats in advance on Kirk Cousins
thank you come on Kirk come on
Kirk hold on hold on
let's give him a mulligan can't keep
hold on a second congratulations on Kirk
Cousins thank you can I can I say a
couple words yes please
hey Kirk its Josh here um I just want to
say welcome to the family and come in
with that same enthusiasm but I need you
to win games in the clutch we're already
that close I need you to win us a Super
Bowl you're getting paid a lot of money
[Music]
Duhamel check out love Simon in theaters
this weekend you will love it check out
unsolved the murder of two pack of
notorious b.i.g and then of course check
out the buddy games when is that coming
up we don't know yet all right and keep
that in mind I keep that in mind so
we've got to see Nick Swardson getting
attacked by a komodo dragon with meat on
his head here on the Rich Eisen show in
a moment all right one more segment here
with Josh Duhamel and since its
television only we could show something
nice and visual like this photograph of
you we give you the backstory that I
would love it oh so that's my that's my
nephew's Jersey okay
my nephew Oliver he was not thrilled
when I made him give me that Jersey I go
Kim your jerseys like no I said give me
the Jersey yes it's one of those moments
you say you don't have any regrets in
life well you do that might be over well
I mean one more time how old is Oliver
like seven okay I just I love the
placement on your Instagram of tagging
it right there yeah well I'm trying to
cover up that beard go sure
and where was where where was this was
it on shoot this was in North Dakota at
the opening of a hospital that's neat
and yeah and that's about all I got for
you now it gets thank you for bringing
that up there no no I just we were we
were wondering what that was all about
with Carson Wentz who's as you know it's
kind of keeping his distance from me
yeah I know but he's that guy's
incredible he's great
he's a good human too he's a good dude
he really is he's a music he's uh he's
good for the city of Philly I think
Billy could use use a guy like Carson
Wentz well I know that's why they're
sticking with them good to see you sir
thanks to the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience